ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเอจะ
Share  screen ไหมคะเพจแชร์ได้ค่ะใช่ค่ะ
สวัสดีนักเรียน 13 คนของเรา
ไหว้เพื่อ
โอเคคุยลบอันนี้ก่อนนะคะถ้า
ผู้หญิงเท้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันพฤหัสบดี
ค่ะ
วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 2 ค่ะ
วันที่ 2 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิ.ย.ค่ะเดือน
อามิถุนายน
ถูกปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
แล้วปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา
05:43 นาทีค่ะหน้าโมงสี่สิบสาม
นาทีนะคะๆ
เจ๊ลบค่ะได้ค่ะเห็นลดวันที่ลบเวลาเพราะ
เก๋มีคำถามค่ายโคเอนมีคำถามครูเอ๋ครูหญิง
ชอบถามใช่อ๋อ
ถ้าชอบมีคำถามถามนักเรียนถามครูเอ๋ชายถาม
ผู้หญิงถามครูเอ๋ถามนักเรียนค่ะบางคนไม่
ชอบให้ถามแต่ครูหญิงโคเอกชอบถาม
ใส่ค่ะคำถามวันนี้ครูหญิงก็มีมีคำตอบให้
ได้ 2 คำตอบเหมือนกันเฮครูหญิงชอบค่ะเวลา
ถามแล้วตอบแค่เอง A1 หรือดี
คิดจะมิดหน่อยถ้ามีเอกับบี
ใส่ a เนี่ย
อะไรคะยิ้ม
หน้า
era คาคำตอบ a น่ะที่ยิ้มก่อนแล้ว
งั้นอ๋อเพราะว่ายายก็ยิ้มเนาะได้ฮะไอ้
หน้าสบายๆ
ทำได้ทำได้ง่ายแล้วทาบดีล่ะคะคำตอบข้อ
bb&b ต้องใหญ่ๆ
ทำไมอ่ะ
ทำไมใหญ่ๆโอ้วหน้าไม่ยิ้มอยติ๋มมีน้ำป่า
ทำไมอ่ะ B อะไรคะอันนี้จมูกหน่อย
B แล้วไม่ง่าย
ยา
โห
ยังทำไมได้
ยากมากอยากจังเลยเหรอ
เองง่ายๆง่ายบียากมาก
[เพลง]
ยากมากยากอ่ะอุ้ยดีเจหน้าง่ายได้ค่ะโอเค
นะผู้หญิงเนี่ยต้องเลือกนะคะเลือกเอง A5
ง่ายหรือ
เบดี
ยากได้ค่ะคุยทางเลือกหนึ่งเนาะง่ายหรือ
ยังอยากนาคผ้าก็ครูเอ๋ไม่รู้ครูหญิงคิด
ว่า a ว่างๆหรือคิดว่าบียากได้ค่ะนี่เอ๋
เพราะว่าครูหญิงกับครูเอกคิดไหมเหมือนกัน
นะคะนักเรียนก็
ชาย
นักเรียนก็จะคิดไม่เหมือนครูหญิงไม่
เหมือนครูเอ๋ๆก็คลิปนี้ก็จะมีครูเอ๋มีรูป
ให้ดูแล้วก็ถามผู้หญิงผู้หญิงมีของให้ดู
ถามครูเอ๋ OK ได้ค่ะก็ยังไงค่ะครูเอ๋คุย
ชอบกินใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงก็ชอบตาตัว
เองทุกคนชอบกินค่ะให้ทุกคนชอบกินคู๋มีรูป
ค่ะกู
ๆกูอะไรคะปูนึ่งเหรอคะปูนึ่งปูยื่นอะไรปู
ม้าปูม้าปูม้านึ่งโอเคไหมค่ะโอเคอยู่อยู่
บนอะไรคะอยู่บนจานค่ะอยู่ในจานก็ได้นะอ่า
เอ่ออยู่บนผักในจานวนผักในคะ
โอ๊ะยาวเลยนะโอเคผู้หญิงชอบกินปูไหมคะพ่อ
ค่ะอร่อยแต่ถ้าปูนมาเสิร์ฟยกมาแล้วเป็น
แบบนี้เลยยังไม่ได้แกะและหาค่ะอ่ะมีผู้
หญิงทำนะยังไม่ชอบผู้หญิงต้องแกะเองถ้ากู
ผู้หญิงคะแกะปูปูม้าปูม้าแก่ง
ยากหรือง่ายง่ายหรือญาติปู Mask ครูหญิง
ใช่ไหมคะผู้หญิงคิดใช่ไหมคะยากค่ะครูเอ๋
แก
b.b.a. ได้ง่ายบียาก
ยากค่ะงอกผู้หญิงคิดว่าแกะกูมายากแล้วก็
ไม่ได้กินสิคะก็ไม่กินเนี้ยคุยแก่ให้ครู
เอ๋เหรอคะครูให้คิดว่าแกะปูม้างี้ย
[เพลง]
และเร็วแล้วก็ได้กินไม่ได้กินอ้าวผู้หญิง
กินตัวเองแกะแล้วครูหญิงแกะแล้วรักษามี
แกะแล้วก็คุณแม่แกะแล้วก็ทุกคน
in คุยแกะให้แกะให้ให้
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้แกะปูปูก็เลยคิดก็ไม่เก่ง
ใช่มั้ยก็เลยยากเหล็งแกะก็ไม่ยากโอเค
ง่ายใช่ไหมคะสำหรับครูเองสำหรับตัวเอง
ง่ายค่ะสำหรับครูหนังยากยานักเรียนแกะยาก
ยาก
อนุญาตไงง่ายหรือว่ายาก
ก็เขมรเขมรคอมเม้นนะ
ไม่มีอีกมีปูอีกผู้หญิง
กูอันนี้กับปูรูปที่แล้วไม่ก็เหมือนกัน
เหรอคะบุกคู๋อันนี้เป็นปูนึ่งนะคะปูนึ่ง
ครูเอกคิดว่าแกะเองๆเป็นปูม้านึ่งปูม้า
นึ่งแกะแกะอย่างง่ายค่ะอันนี้เป็นปูทะเล
ผัดผงกะหรี่หนู
อร่อย
ครูหญิงขาอะไรคะอยากแม่หรอกผู้หญิงไม่จะ
ยากอย่างเดียวค่ะครูเอ๋
ยากมาก
เวลากูหญิงเห็นหมู่ผัดผงกะหรี่แล้วก็มา
เป็นตัวอย่างนี้ถ้าว่าอันนี้นะคะกินง่าย
กินยาก
กินหน้าค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋ต้องแกะๆแกะปูถ้าแล้ว
ครูเอ๋ล่ะคะถ้าปูผัดผงกะหรี่ Mask ขอ
เสิร์ฟแล้วก็ปูเป็นตัวแบบนี้ครูเอ๋คิดว่า
กินได้หรือกินญาติกินยากค่ะแม่ครูเอ๋ชอบ
แกะกูก็คิดกินยากโออันนี้แข็ง 1 ยากนะคะ
ไปมือแกะไม่ได้เนาะไม่ชอบกินต่อไม่ชอบไป
ชอบปูม่าหมอปูม้าปูอันนี้ก็ชอบแต่ไม่ชอบ
แบบนี้ชอบแกะเสร็จแล้วโหคะแกะเสร็จแล้ว
เราก็ผัดผงกะหรี่แล้วก็เอามาเสิร์ฟกิน
ง่ายกินง่ายอันนี้กินยากเนี่ยไงหมาไม่กิน
แบบนี้ฟันจะบ๊ายบายค่ะกัด Chic กูโอเคฟัน
ฟันขัดลุ้น
xxx กากไม่เอายายโทรมา
หน้าม้ากินง่ายสำหรับถ่ายนัดแกะง่ายกิน
ง่ายๆกูเองอ่ะคิดผู้หญิงคิดว่ายานั้นยาก
ค่ะ
อันนี้กูเองคิดยากคุยคิดกินหญ้ากูเองคิด
ยาต่อไปค่ะผู้หญิงมีภาคมีอะไรอีกคะครูเอ๋
อ่อเน็ตภาพนี้ก็จะมีมีเรื่อยไปคันมี
เรื่อยค่ะและมีคนมีไม้มีคน
วันนี้มีแขนแล้วก็กดที่ไม้ค่ะ
เรื่อยๆนะคะเลื่อยเลื่อยไม้
ให้
ผู้หญิงคะคุยอิ๋งอีกนะตัวผู้หญิงคิดว่า
เลื่อยไม้เนี่ยทำยากหรือทำง่ายๆคุณครู
หญิงคิดว่าเลื่อยไม้
คำยากค่ะครูเอ๋
โหคุยหญิงเรื่อยๆยากค่ะแล้วครูเอ๋ล่ะคะ
ครูเอกคิดว่าเลื่อยไม้เนี่ยทำง่ายหรือว่า
ยากยากมาก
เคยมั้ยครูเอ๋แล้วก็เลื่อย
[เพลง]
ตัวเอง
กูเอาไม่ใช่ครูเอ๋กดผิดนะคะไม่ต้องตกใจนะ
กูเองผู้หญิงดูเนี่ยในรูปเนี่ยถ้าไม้ไม้
แบบนี้นะคะบางๆ
ง่ายไม่ญาติผู้หญิงไงหรอ
คู๋ยากไม้แบบนี้นะต้องมาแบบนี้นะคะผู้
หญิงไม้เล็กๆแค่นี้ก็ยังเลื่อย
แต่เหนื่อยมากไม่ได้
อ๋ออ๋อคุยคิดยากใช่ไหมยากมากครูเองอย่ามา
สำหรับผู้หญิงง่ายถ้าหมายเล็กๆอย่างเงี้ย
ง่ายแต่ถ้ามาให้หนา
ยากอะไรหรอกเวลากู
นักเรียนยากหรือไงค่ะเลื่อยไม้นักเรียน
ผู้ชายบอก
นักเรียนผู้ชายผู้ชายหลายบางคนบอกง่ายใช่
มะง่ายแล้วเรียนผู้ชายง่ายอ่ะกูยังไม่รู้
นักเรียนยากหรือง่ายกูยากผู้หญิงง่าย
หน่ายจะมีอีกไหมคะครูเอ๋มีมีๆๆมีรูปสวย
อันนี้อะไรคะเนี่ยจักรยานอยู่ตรงไหนคะ
อยู่ที่ไหนครับจักรยานอยู่ที่อยู่บนสภา
ถ้างั้นอันนี้เป็นสะพานจะยานอยู่บนสะพาน
ค่ะตรงนี้เป็นคลองนะคะ
รองแล้วก็จริงๆมีคนนะคนฉี่เปีย
คนปั่นจักรยานนะคะค่ะหญิงผู้หญิงคะเท่า
ไหร่คะครูเองเนี่ยไปเรียนเรียนปั่น
จักรยานเนี่ยยากหรือง่าย
เรียนปั่นจักรยาน
ยายค่ะครูเอ๋ไงๆๆ
ง่ายมากๆ
แล้วคุณแม่ผู้หญิงนะคะเรียนปั่นจักรยาน
คุณแม่คิดว่ายากหรือง่ายคุณแม่ครูหญิงคิด
ว่าญาติมาก
คุณแม่ผู้หญิงปั่นจักรยานเอามาให้ได้ผู้
หญิงเก่งไม่คิดแล้วครูเอ๋แล้วคะครูคิดว่า
เรียนปั่นจักรยานเนี่ยญาติหรือง่ายเมื่อ
ก่อนเวลาครูเอ๋เอ๋นะคะโอเคค่ะ
สีดำดีกว่าหรอคู๋น่ะคู๋อายุ 8 ปี
แล้วก็ปั่นจักรยาน
ร้องไห้
ยากจังเลยอ่ะเออ
แต่ตอนนี้โอเคง่าย
แต่ตอนเด็กๆโอ้ยากจังเลยเจ็บเจ็บเอาอ๋อ
ครูหญิงตอนเด็กๆค่ะเยอะๆค่ะครูเอ๋
[เพลง]
เฟสลมใกล้หรออ้าวมีร้อนตรงนี้แล้วมึงอ่ะ
ขอไอซีคู SS เอารอออกเอาหล่อๆมีสองร้อย
จักรยาน 2 ล้อเหมือนในรูปค่ะมีหนึ่งเราก็
2  2 ล้อ
ง่ายสำหรับผู้หญิงไงคู่เอ๋เมื่อก่อนยาก
ตอนนี้โอเคแต่ก็ไม่ง่าย
ใส่ใส่แต่ไม่ยากเหมือนเมื่อก่อน
มีรูปอีกผู้หญิงโรคอะไรอีกคะครูเอ๋
แตงโมแกะสลัก
แกะสลักแตงโมค่ะแต่งโมก็ได้นะคะเด็กอะไร
ก็ได้ค่ะอะไรก็ได้แครอทก็ได้แตงโมไปเนี่ย
ยายีไม่มีไม่ใช่ๆมีมีดมีนี่
มีตัวเอมมี่แกะสลักนี่หมอคนนี้เขาถือมีด
แกะสลักแล้วก็แกะสลัดแตงโมอยู่ค่ะค่ะ
ครูเกศจะถามอะไรคุยจะถามว่าแกะสลักเนี่ย
ยากหรือไงค่ะผู้หญิงเป็นผู้หญิงเป็นผู้
หญิงไทยไงใช่มั้ยยากมากค่ะ
ญาติมากค่ะครูเอ๋
แล้วครูเอ๋ล่ะคะครูเองคิดว่าแกะสลัดหญ้า
ยากหรือง่ายๆแน่ๆเลย
ง่ายใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋ยากมากค่ะ
เอ้า
เอกนะ
อันนี้ไม่ใช่ครูมาแล้วเค้าคู๋ผู้หญิงคิด
ว่าคนนี้เนี่ยครูเอ๋แล้วก็กูเอกกำลังแกะ
สลัดไม่ใช่จาก Google อันนี้ผู้ชายผู้ชาย
ผู้หญิงผู้ชายไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงตกๆ
ยางนะคะนักเรียนแกะสลัดเนี่ยเป็นของคนไทย
แต่ยากมาก
ผู้หญิงทำไม่ได้รู้ได้เลยโอเค
ทำแต่
ยาย
มายากไม่รู้รู้ว่ามีนักเรียนเนี่ยที่คิด
ว่าแกะสลัดง่ายเนี่ยมีไว้เนาะอุ๊ปส์
เพื่อนครูเอ๋
คนไทยไหมคะคนญี่ปุ่นคนญี่ปุ่นคิดเพื่อน
ครูเอ๋นะคิดแกะสลักเนี่ยยากหรือง่ายง่าย
เขาแข่งใช่ไหมเก่งมากๆ
ถ้าเป็นครูแกะสลักคุยแล้วเราแล้วก็ผู้
หญิงก็ไปเรียนกับคนญี่ปุ่นใช่ไหมเพื่อนกู
เองสอนแกะสลัก
ผู้หญิง
คนไทยแกะสะอาดไม่ได้คนญี่ปุ่นมามาเรียน
แล้วก็แกะสลักแตงโมขอไงเราก็สวยด้วย
เก่งมากนะคะ
เรายากนะฮะกลับไปเราเอกมีรูปอีกอะไรคะครู
เอ๋โอ้รีดผ้าเหนื่อยๆรินพาค่ะผู้หญิงคะ
รีดผ้าเนี่ยสำหรับผู้หญิงญาติหรือง่ายคู๋
ผู้หญิงตอบ 2 อย่างได้ไหมอ่ะไม่อ่ะเอานี่
ไงถ้าเหมือนในรูปใช่ไหมคะเขารีดเสื้อ
เชิ้ตอ่ะที่คาดหัวม้า
ลายง่ายรีดเสื้อยืดรีดชุดกับครูเอ๋ใส่อะ
กระโปกหน้าชุดกระโปรงคณิตง่ายแต่ถ้ารีด
เสื้อเชิ้ตแบบเนี้ยเสื้อเชิ้ตผู้ชายใส่
ยากค่ะตัวเองผู้หญิงนะอ่าแล้วครูเอ๋นะคะ
ครูเอกคิดว่าว่ารีดผ้า
ยากหรือง่าย
ก็ยากนะได้เกลียดไม่ชอบเรียกพ่อ
ทำไมครูหญิงรู้
ผู้หญิงรีดให้ครูเอง I  kuai เนี่ยต่อย
เสื้อเชิ้ตครูเอ๋ชอบเสื้อเชิ้ตแบบนี้
เสื้อเชิ้ตผู้ชายอ่ะค่ะนักเรียนแล้วก็ครู
หญิงรีบ
RE เสื้อเชิ้ตทำไมมันยากอย่างนี้
ก็คุยโรงเรียนหนังสือเสร็จผู้หญิงหมีครู
เอ๋ก็ไม่พูดเอกก็ไม่ใส่เสื้อเชิ้ตเลย
ผีเสื้อยื้อไม่มีคนรีดให้ครูเอ๋ตัวเอง
เอ้ย
ไม่เอา
เสรีไทยสาวอีอ่ะดึกยากมากสามีก็ใส่เสื้อ
ยับยาว
ผู้หญิงมีอะไรมาเพิ่มไหมคะผู้หญิงมีค่ะ
คุยอยากถามได้ๆๆครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋คิดว่า
ร้องเพลง
ได้นะลาลาลาลาลาลาลาลาลาลาลาลา
ญาติหรือง่ายอยากฟังไหม
พี่ก่อนสิจะได้รู้ว่าอยากฟังหรือเปล่าบอก
ก่อนว่ายากหรือง่าย
ก็ยากมาก
ทำไมยาก
มาก Happy  Birthday  To  You
Happy  Birthday  To  You
Happy
กูเองไม่เข้าใจเมโลดี้อยากมากอยากมากมาย
ญาติผู้หญิงก็คิดว่ายากทั้งคู๋
เพราะว่าเวลาร้องเพลงมันจะมีเสียงแบบ
ผู้หญิงอ่ะสูงกลางใช่ป่ะใช่ไม่ได้ไม่ได้
กูเองร้องเพลงไม่ได้ในได้ยากมากนะก็จะ
เป็น monotone นะคะนักเรียน Happy
Birthday  To  You  Happy  Birthday
Happy  Birthday  To  You  Happy
Birthday อย่างจากๆเก๋มีร้องเพลงแล้วก็
ต้องมีโต๊ะก็
เป็นอ่ะคะเต้นอ่ะอ๋อโอเคเล่นชิว this
love เย้เนี่ยนะคะแปลกสีเนี่ยเต้นหน้าหา
เต้น
ทุกอย่าง
YMCA ไม่รู้เต้นยังไงนะคะเต้น
เต้นครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋เนี่ยร้องเพลงคิดว่ายาก
เพราะว่ามีเมโลดี้ใช่ไหมคะแล้วครูเอกคิด
ว่าเต้นเต้นเนี่ยญาติหรือง่ายผู้หญิงดูกู
อีกเส้นหน่ะหรอ
ย่าค่ะ
ก็อยากจะถามนะคะว่ารำไทย
ยากด้วยเนี้ยยาก
คล้ายๆกันใช่ไหมเต้นแล้วก็รำไทยเหรัมไทย
เนี่ยครูหญิงคิดว่าคู่มือมือ
นะ
ง่ายอันนี้ใช่ไหมมือใช่แบบจีบตั้งวงจีบ
มือ
ง่ายแต่ขา
โอเคขาไม่เห็นนะคะขาแล้วก็สะโพกสะโพกสาย
อานาจมามาก
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ไม่ได้ค่ะฉายายังหรอกมึงญาติแต่สะโพกซ้าย
ขวา
ยากมาก
แตกผู้หญิงก็ทำได้นี่ลองได้แต่แบบเหมือน
ผู้ชายครูเอ๋เอมมือเท่านั้นโอเคค่ะชายผิด
สะโพกไม่ได้ไม่ไม่สวย
ญาติต้องคนรำไทยก็ไม่ได้ไม่ได้
มีอีกค่ะครูเหตุมีอะไรคะ
แต่กูเอกผมสั้นเราว่าผู้หญิงผมยาวไงได้ทำ
ได้อ้ะผู้หญิงแล้วนะคะก็ผมยาวผู้หญิง
เนี่ยมัดผมแต่บางวันก็ไม่อยากมัดผมอยากจะ
ถักเปียไม่มีแบ่งผมเป็น 1  2  3 ค่ะแล้ว
ก็นี่อะผัดเปียโอเคถักเปียกับเปียมีนอน
พักเกียร์
ขัดเปียนะคะ
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยถักเปียให้ตัวเองครูเอ๋ถักเอง
นะถักเปียเองเนี่ยครูเอ๋คิดว่ายากหรือ
ง่ายผู้หญิงดูเห็นยิ้มเลยนะยากค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยขับเกียร์ยากไม่ใช่ว่าจะหน้า
กากนัดผมครูเอ๋เนี่ยค่ะถักเปียญาติผมครู
เห็นหนัก 1
ผักเปียกยานะคะ
ถักเปียตัวเองอ่ะก็ยากแล้วผู้หญิงโอเคนะ
ง่ายใช่ไหมคะถักเปียตัวเองยามะค่ะมีอีก
ไหมมีแต่รออยู่ละสินักเรียนคะประเทศไทย
หน่อยนะคะมันจะมีอยู่อย่างหนึ่งที่นัก
เรียนเวลานักเรียนมาประเทศไทยหรือตลทว่า
โห้
ผู้หญิงไม่มีของจริงล่ะคะนี่เนี่ยผิดให้
นักเรียนดูก่อนไงกูเอ๋
ดูอะไรดูแบบนี้เอาพิมพ์ผิดขอโทษทีค่ะ
คุยขอโทษนะคะนักเรียนนี่นี่นักเรียนเนี่ย
จะอามาประเทศไทยแล้วก็เห็นวันนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
เป็นถุงพลาสติกสานไม้
ไผ่ค่ะแล้วก็มัดแบบใหญ่ๆไม่มีถุงเคมีไหม
คะถุงพลาสติกมีมี
ๆมีหนังยางไหมคะเดี๋ยวนะเดี๋ยวนะหลัง
อย่างกูอีกไปไหนเมื่อกี้คืออะไรอย่างฉัน
อย่างอย่างกูแอคชั่นหนังยางหายอ้าวครูเอ๋
เจ้
มัดเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะมัดถุงพลาสติกมัดถุง
พลาสติกนะคะไม่เป็นไรคุณยางรัดผมกันนะฮะ
โอเคต้องมัดให้มันเป็นแบบนี้นะคะเนี่ย
ให้มันแบบ
สวยๆแบบนี้
ไม่หาอยู่นะคะนักเรียนหาหนังยาผู้หญิงก็
หายไปด้วยเลยค่ะครูเอ๋สองคนหาไม่เป็นไร
ค่ะผู้เขียนผู้หญิงมีเยอะขอ 1 อัน
ให้ผ่านซูไม่ได้ครูเอคิดว่ามัดถุงพลาสติก
เนี่ยให้มันแบบพองสวยๆนะคะยากหรือง่ายพระ
เอกคิดว่าง่าย
จริงหรอคะครูเอ๋คิดว่าง่ายๆขอดูได้ไหมคะ
นะคะ
ผู้หญิงอยู่นะคะ
ดูสิคะว่าครูเห็นคำแล้วจะสวยไหมนะนอนสวย
งู
ยังไม่มัดก็สวยแล้วคืนโหครูเอ๋ไปขายอาหาร
ได้เลยนะมัดถุงสวยป้ายเดี๋ยวถ้าครูเอ๋ไม่
มีนักเรียน
ไม่มีสอนพระเอกจะไปขายอาหารก็มัดถุยสวย
อ่ะ
ไม่รู้ผู้หญิงสิว่า
หิวข้าวแล้วนักเรียนผู้หญิงมะกันผู้หญิง
ทำอะไรกินวะ
สวยๆนะผู้หญิง
ได้อยู่
เฮ้ยง่ายไหมง่ายค่ะคุยเป็นคนไทยไงแต่ครู
เอ๋สวยมากกว่าได้จะคบกูเอมมัดถูบ่อยๆนะคะ
ก็เลยง่ายนะคะหายแต่นักเรียนอาจจะคิดว่า
ญาติงายครับประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ยไม่มีครู
เอ๋คะคำถามสุดท้ายคำสุดท้ายแล้วหรอหมด
เวลาหรือยังที่ 3 นาทีเลยนะอ๋อโอเคยังไม่
สุดท้ายหรือหมดเวลาแล้วก็ได้แล้วคะ
1-3 แล้วกัน
through  a หาที่บ้านตอนนี้เรานี่ได้
มั้ยอะไรนะเหรียญนอนแล้วกันของคู๋ใช่อ่า
ไอ้สองคำถามกับนักเรียนนอนหลับนอนหลับนอน
หลับนะ
บ้านก็ได้ที่ไหนก็ได้นอนนอนแล้วก็หลับ
แหละ
ยากหรือง่าย
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยง่ายๆ
ฟ้าง 2  1
หลับหลับแล้วทำไมตื่นหลับนี้ 2x ฉัน
แล้วครูเอ๋ล่ะคะไม่คิดว่านอนหลับเนี่ยยาก
หรือง่าย
ง่ายใช่ไหมครูเอ๋รอบแล้วคู๋
ได้ทุกที่ได้ค่ะนักเรียนมีเวลา 5 นาทีเขว
หลับได้มีนิ้ว 1 นี้แล้วก็จิ้ม
แล้วก็หลับหลับ
อันนี้นักเรียนหนูดีนะรับง่ายๆดีครูเอ๋
หลับง่ายถ้าผู้หญิงพูดมากๆคู๋ไม่ได้พูด
คุยกันล่ะให้แค่คุยก็ต้องให้กูอ่ะพูดก็
มาก
คู๋ชอบหลับหน้าๆ
จะตื่นนะอ้าอยากจะหลับง่ายๆเมื่อวานครู
หญิงให้ครูเหตุดูภาพคน
หาวเอกก็จะกลับแล้ว
นอน
หลับง่ายหลับง่ายเราก็ตื่นง่ายหลับง่าย
ตื่นง่ายๆนี้นะคะหลับง่ายไหมผู้หญิงเนี่ย
หลับง่ายตื่นยาวมากผู้หญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงไม่ตื่นให้ตื่นค่ะครูหญิงงอนเราก็
ตื่นมาแล้วก็เปิดเมื่อคืนฝนตกไม่รู้เลย
นักเรียนบางทีนะมีไฟไหม้แล้วก็
พี่ขลุ่ยหญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
ไม่รู้เลยไม่ตื่นนะไม่ตื่นค่ะครู a ดู
ทีวีเปิดเสียงดังคู่หญิง
ไม่ตื่น
รู๋เป็นหลับง่ายตื่นง่ายนะคะบ่ายค่ะหลับ
ง่ายแล้วก็ไม่ตื่นแล้วก็ตื่นยากนะคะเก๋ทำ
สุดท้ายคู๋จะถามอะไร
สาวๆ
ถามนักเรียน
ฟังภาษาไทย
เรียนภาษาไทย
ยากหรือง่าย
ฮือคะเรียนภาษาไทยแบบฟัง
ยากหรือง่ายง่าย
คือแบบฟังฟังแล้วก็ดู
ยายงามนานนักเรียนใช่ไหมคะภาษาไทยง่าย
ง่ายง่ายง่าย
นิดเดียว
ญาติมากๆไม่ใช่ภาษาไทยง่ายนิดเดียว
นายเรียนภาษาไทยแบบฟังง่ายเข้าใจไม่เป็น
ไร
ไม่เข้าใจไม่เป็นไรฟังครั้งที่สองที่สาม
เข้าใจอะไรค่ะน้องแต่นักเรียนล่ะคะนัก
เรียนคิดว่าง่ายหรือยาก
ต้องคอมเมนต์ได้คอมเม้นน่ะอย่าคุยกับกู
เอกก็จะสะกดจิตค่ะงานงานง่าย
โอ๊ย
ตายแล้วก็คือเม้นท์ง่ายล่ะ
โอเคอ่ะหมดเวลาหรือยังคะหมดเวลาจริงๆแล้ว
ค่ะครูเอ๋ค่ะเนาะเดี๋ยวเรามาด้วยกันใหม่
ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้เรากับภาษา
ไทยง่ายๆถ้ามีสัตว์ภาษาไทยง่ายๆกับครูที่
ไม่ดุนะคะยอมขับเอาวีดีโอมาด้วยเดี๋ยวไม่
อยู่เขาไปดูนายเดี๋ยวนี้เราสองคนก็ต้องไป
ก่อนนะคะแล้วพบกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้าหนา
สวัสดีค่ะดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย